it's been a busy day for diplomacy in
Moscow Russian foreign Ministry
officials have been hosting
representatives from several Arab League
countries as well as the head of the
organization of Islamic Corporation
ending the war in Gaza dominated their
agenda foreign minister s Lov
highlighted the importance of regional
countries being represented in efforts
to resolve the conflict and called for
the resumption of negotiations on the
creation of a Palestinian
state
we support the creation of an
independent Sovereign Palestinian state
within the 1967 borders with its capital
in East Jerusalem for many years we have
advocated that the quartet of mediators
work in full coordination with the
league of Arab
states Russian President Vladimir Putin
spoke about the resolution of the
Palestinian Israeli Conflict at the
extraordinary meeting of bricks leaders
he says the priority is preventing the
war in Gaza from
escalating
one of our colleagues just mentioned
numerous deaths of children that's
horrific but when you see how they
perform surgeries on children without
anesthesia it's beyond
comprehension Russia has long presented
itself as a potential mediator in the
Palestinian Israeli conflict since the
War Began on October the 7th Russia has
hosted a delegation from Hamas and used
its veto power at the UN Security
Council to block the US back's draft
resolution that endorsed Israel's right
to defend itself while denying
Palestinians the right to do so those
actions were positively received by the
Arab world that prompted an outcry from
countries that support Israel
unconditionally Julia shavala Al jazer
Moscow make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer